ma série est disponible en turc mais pas
en français comment ça se fait sur
Netflix les cinq premières saisons de la
série britannique Peaky blinders sont
disponibles en français mais pas la
sixième vous pouvez la regarder en
anglais en italien en japonais ou même
en polonais mais pas en français au
Québec on pourrait s'attendre à ce que
les diffuseurs en ligne nous offrent
systématiquement une version française
comme au cinéma ou généralement une
version doublée ou sous-titrée est
disponible mais la loi sur le cinéma ne
s'applique qu'au cinéma selon le
chroniqueur TD Richard terrien c'est
souvent l'acquisition des droits qui
pose problème la concurrence est féroce
diffuseur en ligne chaîne spécialisée et
télégénéraliste se battent pour offrir
en exclusivité des versions françaises
tout est négocié à la pièce dans le cas
de Peaky blinders ces TV5 unis et pas
Netflix qui a mis le grappin sur la
dernière saison en français la docteur
gris
en anglais sur Netflix vous la trouverez
en français à Radio-Canada mais
seulement la 18e saison
tout cela est pas mal plus compliqué
qu'au temps des DVD même Astérix et
Cléopâtre en perdent leur latin si vous
n'avez pas la patience de les attendre à
ciné cadeau vous devrez vous contenter
d'Astérix and Cléopâtre sur prime
[Musique]